El Salvador is a small country,
in fact,
it's the smallest country in all of
Central America.
Bob,
that's only geographically.
The country has six point 5 million
inhabitants.
Population that's larger than Panama,
Costa Rica,
Belize,
or Nicaragua.
That's a large population,
especially when you consider that to
immigration from the country is common
according to various sources.
Some three to 4 million salvadorians all
living abroad with many living in the
United States.
Don't tell trump it's disgusting.
I don't want to talk about immigration
is ever popular with thousands of
Salvadorians each year,
packing up their suitcases and taking a
chance on a better future somewhere
else.
It's rate of emigration from El Salvador
maintains itself.
Then there might soon be more
salvadorians living outside El Salvador.
Then they're all living inside it.
So now you might be wondering why are so
many people so keen to leave this
country or you might not be wondering
that.
It's.
I mean,
we did have to choose a title for this
video,
but anyway,
so let's have a look at why so many
people are leaving this country
training.
Yes,
it is true that El Salvador is a very
poor country,
but economics is not the only reason
that people are leaving.
Now,
before we get into details on what
exactly is causing this accident,
so let me give you a quick bit of
information.
El Salvador is a tropical country where
you can find stunning beaches like these
as well as magnificent nature reserves
like this one as well as amazing
cultural remains,
and in 2017,
this is a year in which the country
should be celebrating 2017 marks.
The 25th anniversary of the peace
agreements,
which puts an end to the bitter and
cruel civil war,
which lasted more than 12 years and
caused more than 70,000.
This conflict was between the national
armed forces and these so called Fera
Gonzo Marti National Liberation Front.
I left wing paramilitary group which
counted on the support of the Cuban
government.
Interestingly,
after the peace agreements,
this guerrilla group,
it became a political party and today
they have the presidency of the
republic.
Quite the remarkable change.
Oh,
if you cmcs yet.
Now,
while this 25th anniversary,
it shouldn't be a reason for
celebration.
It's pretty hard to celebrate when you
look at the current situation that El
Salvador finds itself in the violence,
the 11th of January 2017.
It was a normal Wednesday where nothing
extraordinary happens that absolutely
nothing.
So let me explain.
That date ended with a death toll of
zero in El Salvador and yes,
that unknown events was actually front
page news.
The reason for this being newsworthy is
that als Salvador has become one of the
most dangerous countries in the world.
Now.
It's to give you an idea of how dire the
situation is.
Consider this in 2015,
6,617
murders were registered because that is
to say there were 105 murders for every
$100,000.
This is the highest of any country in
the world,
which is not currently a warzone.
This number is really,
truly terrifying and is perhaps best
illustrated with a comparison.
If this figure were applied to the UK,
would mean that there were 70,000
murders a year in the country,
and what's the real figure for the UK?
Well,
it's a touch more than 500 murders.
That's a hundred and 14 times less in
2016 to figures were a bit lower,
but there were still 4,000
murders registered.
This is madness.
There have been wars.
Well,
as people have died.
Oh,
and believe murder is far from the only
serious crime getting down in El
Salvador,
kidnapping,
extortion,
theft.
That all worryingly common.
So we're going with this great news.
Well,
who's up for a holiday to El Salvador,
right?
No one.
Oh,
what a surprise.
Now,
given all of this information,
it's probably no surprise to you that
according to recent surveys,
it's been indicated that nearly half of
the population of El Salvador wants to
leave and it's really clear to see that
this violence has consequences and this
isn't just a fear of crime being
committed against you direct sleep,
but it also affects the standard of
living of all people in the country.
Now,
according to the Salvadorian Central
Bank violence costs around 4 billion US
dollars a year,
and you know what?
That's not really that surprising.
I mean,
after all,
he wants to invest their money in a
country where you can be killed at
pretty much any time.
Don't believe me.
Well,
how about this?
Foreign investment is the lowest in all
of Central America.
Even regular people are at risk in El
Salvador.
In fact,
these statistics show that you're more
likely to be murdered as a bus driver
rather than a policeman in the country.
In the last five years alone,
street gangs have killed almost 700 bus
drivers in the regio.
It is known globally,
but Latin America does have a serious
problem with violence and crime.
According to a report from the British
consulting from various can.
Maplecroft glass in America is the
region where you have the highest risk
of having a violence crime committed
against you.
Indeed,
six of the world's 10 most violent
countries are actually in this room.
Sure.
More incredible than that though,
is the fact that one in three homicides
that occur every year globally,
it take place in Latin America,
even within this dangerous environments,
but the northern triangle countries of
central America really take the
biscuits.
This area is formed of El Salvador,
Honduras,
and Guatemala,
and it is by far the most dangerous area
on the continent.
In fact,
when you do consider,
warzones is actually the most dangerous
region in the world.
In these countries which are relatively
smaller,
200,000
people have been murdered since $2,000.
You.
The reality of these numbers is prison.
Easy to see why people want to leave.
You can't walk the streets safely at
night or wear a watch or a necklace or
start a business without having to pay
some criminal organization.
It kind of sucks.
So the question that must be on your
mind right now,
but why is there so much violence,
right?
Trafficking probably on your mind now is
just why is this so much violence?
Now?
The reality is these countries in
Central America have not always been
such a dangerous places.
It could even be considered relatively
peaceful until about 20 years ago at
least on an individual level boss.
This all started to change by the end of
the eighties and nineties for two
reasons.
Drug trafficking,
right?
The drug trafficking.
This is a serious problem in the region.
Every year,
22 million Americans use drugs and most
of them come from South America.
The drug cartels on making an absolute
fortune.
Yes,
this isn't anything new,
but this activity has evolved over the
years and just continually found ways to
operate a spice pressure from law
enforcement's.
The persecution of the famous Colombian
drug cartels led to a shift in route of
the drugs coming to the US.
Previously it went to Columbia,
to the Caribbean islands to Florida.
Now there's a new route that goes
through Central America,
and this is the first big problem.
Central America has become a sort of
sanctuary for new Mexican drug cartels
from Central America.
They can organize their business high
drugs and take refuge from justice
whenever needed.
It's like now you're probably getting
the idea.
Experts have calculated that 80 percent
of the drugs used in the U.
s have to go through Honduras and this
has led to an extraordinary amounts of
violence in that region.
Now to the second major problem,
the Morris,
for those of you who don't know them,
the Morris Street gangs that engage in
all kinds of criminal activities like
theft,
murder or extortion.
Then members are usually young people
and their organization is relatively
horizontal,
meaning that they don't have much of an
organized hierarchy.
They organize an individual criminal
cells which work quite independently
from one another and do take notes here
because it is estimated that in these
three countries alone,
the Maris have around 70 to 100,000
members.
The most famous of these organizations
all salvage and barrio 18.
It's both usually fight against each
other over the control of different
territories.
Hi,
thinking
violence situation is complex.
Many strategies have been used to try
and solve the problem and they have all
failed.
However,
two initiatives have been put into
practice lately in order to change the
reality of these countries and achieve
safety for their citizens.
The first is known as the traditional
task force.
This is a security apparatus formed by
police officers,
intelligence experts,
and special units of three countries
that we've mentioned.
The aim of this group is to find street
gangs,
drug trafficking and organized crime
regardless of borders or the group
receives support,
training and financing from the United
States.
The idea of this as clear as Kwon,
Orlando Hernandez,
the president of Honduras,
likes to say we are going to give them a
taste of their own medicine.
The second initiative is linked to the
first and it is known as the alliance of
prosperity.
This was launched by the Obama
Administration,
ended expects to improve the living
conditions and the competitiveness of
these countries.
It's main goal is to create jobs and
essential infrastructure in order to
reverse the terrible current situation.
To start,
Washington has already committed to
spend $750,000,000
in order to support these initiatives.
But the question is really,
is there any hope?
And the answer is well,
the sort of has to be Mara Salvatrucha
has already communicated that they are
willing to negotiate their own
dismantling,
but only time will tell if it's
accessible.
So have you on the region here,
a visual politic,
but we would love to know what you
think.
Do you think these countries will manage
to get rid of their criminal elements?
Will the plan is set by Washington
succeeded?
So I'd love to know what you think and
you can use the comments to you do that.
And unfortunately,
because of the growth of this channel,
we can't answer all of the comments that
please do know that we do read them all.
And as always,
if you like this video,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday.
And as always,
I'll see you next time.